you can be totally fine by telling
people that you want to go on a
murderous Rampage and invade the Middle
East and kill thousands of people that's
cool and and nobody bats an eye but if
you tell advertisers to f off then
everybody lose I was going to say you
can you can advocate
for attacking Russia nuclear war nuclear
war but if you say we're going to build
a wall on a southern border well now
you're a bigot racist and must be
stopped and there's no way to afford
that we couldn't possibly afford 3
billion for the wall even though we're
paying what 450 billion for all the
illegals it's billion or million uh I
think it's billion it's actually a
billion it's like a factor it's like I
almost can't believe this you see
Chicago they're building the
camps churches they're building two c
with churches no no no no no they have
big empty industrial lots I'm mixing up
stories in two in two areas in the south
side of Chicago they're building a
brick-and mortar migrant camp and then
they're also building a tent city